hey leute sieht auch mal waren insgesamt
zum neuen sales testvideo heute werden
wir die er süßigkeiten testen denn ich
habe eine ddr mystery box gefunden und
nach dem letzten ddr video habe ich
einfach los die deutsche demokratische
republik kennen zu lernen
nur damit niemand verstehen womit sie
wieder arbeiten ich war nämlich online
im internet unterwegs um für ein anderes
video lebensmittel zu finden und dann
ist mir diese box entgegen gesprungen
und ihr wisst ich bin immer für einen
guten zweck zu haben also probieren wir
das jetzt auch so
das licht gefällt mich überhaupt nicht
diese jedoch nicht
dann gucken wir mal was in der ostalgie
box drin ist immer gespannt ich finde es
interessant zu wissen welche süßigkeiten
die man heute noch im supermarkt findet
halt auch aus ddr macht mir die bude
kiste auf und finden einem engpass nicht
schon wieder viele produkte erinnert ihr
euch noch an das video ich lebensmittel
die kaputt waren gekauft habe es ist so
eine große box tolles design des
bestimmt ein super geschenk also wenn
man die verschenkt oder 90 leute die
alle an der ddr-nostalgie box okay ich
nehme einfach immer was raus und dann
sei der hund freue mich jetzt schon wenn
die leute gern schreiben ja natürlich
ist das aus der ddr bist du doof oma
hartmanns kiter und ich hab noch nie in
kalten hund gebacken weil ich auch
ehrlich ich weiß wie das geht okay das
ist also die mini version davon also ein
kleiner kalter hund snack aber es ist
auch ein rezept aus tätig er dieses
video funktioniert übrigens nur wenn ihr
das alles in die kommentare schreiben
das schon mal probiert aber für welches
video ich weiß es nicht
[Musik]
schichten kriegs mit schokolade
drumherum der spontane sommereinbruch
hier in berlin macht mich fertig
bewertungen 15 bananen für den kalten
konnten
mein gott es muss allgemein ostling sein
weil in polen gab es so viele bonbons
sie einfach so aussahen wie henry ne der
henry ist das ganz gerne dann sieht man
oben noch die marke
legen wenn henry das empfiehlt dann kann
es nur gut sein
ja es ist zucker milch sahne beim fett
aroma- und seid solltet carroll damals
schon gut also wenn ich ein empfang
hätte würde ich das hier in meinen
empfang legen wer das original aus dem
osten
das verstehe ich wirklich nicht wenn es
ein konkurrenzprodukt gibt was so
beliebt ist und so gut schmeckt wie
schafft es henry auf dem markt zu
bleiben das ist wahrscheinlich so wie
mit meinem youtube-kanal es gibt viel
bessere da draußen aber irgendwie
schaffe ich seit jahren mich auch durch
zuschläge dax von 5 bananen zu diesem
produkt gibt eine kleine story teil ich
habe viele jahre bei gebe gearbeitet und
die regale dort aufgeführten es hat mich
bis heute nicht losgelassen das mich
einmal gefragt wo sind denn die
knusperflocken und ich habe ihm erzählt
dass es die nicht gibt also dass wir die
nicht haben und einen tag später steht
für diesen regalen knusperflocken und
konnte den mann niemals sagen dass wir
sie doch hatten
als der mann das heute sieht es tut mir
wirklich so unendlich leid bis heute
beatsteaks gewissen frontzeck ich glaube
es ist allgemein eine beliebte marke
moment mal wie lange solche haltbare der
12 222 ich weiß nicht so sein sollte
aber das sieht so richtig aus wie so ein
altes englisches stück schokolade
trocken vollkornmehl ersten vollkommen
haar familie haferflocken kondensmilch
aigle pulver was ist denn da bitte alles
drin die einzigartige mischung aus
knusprigen knäckebrot und feinster
vollmilchschokolade ja jetzt wo man weiß
es nicht schlecht geworden sondern so
gehören
das ist ein bisschen pervers aber auch
irgendwie extrem lecker acht von zehn
bananen
liebe es neue produkte auszuprobieren
deswegen guckt mal moca bohnen freue
mich schokolade mit mokka geschmack habe
ich noch nie in meinem leben gegessen
und diese packen hab ich auch noch nie
in meinem leben abziehen schon mal im
supermarkt stehen sie das ist schokolade
in einer low carbon form war
lecker aus weißenfels er kommt aus
weißenfels
sehr lecker werde auf jeden fall gut
gebrauchen können denn ich habe sein
wochen lust auf einen kaffee kuchen also
ich möchte einen kuchen mit
kaffeegeschmack carbon sind doch da ist
noch so eine packung
in sachen heute nicht mehr so gut aus
also heute ist alles so plastik und
links und jetzt so eine schöne
pappschachteln ist das denn keystone
rösler vom gleichen hersteller natürlich
hier hast du verschiedene tiere und
katzen hasen igel
hasen
jetzt gute schokolade also es wirklich
ich finds lecker alleine für diese
verpackung muss es eine zehn von zehn
bahnen geben das ist das ist mein job
für die walker kaffeebohnen natürlich
auch zehn von zehn bahnen
die kenne ich noch von früher ja
manchmal der firma grabow wahl
steht wahrscheinlich auch schon seit
ewigkeiten darauf wieder verwendbare
haushalts box nur sie nehme ich auch
wenn man so eine riesen plastikschale
bekommen hat man die wiederverwendet
früher jetzt habe ich in unserer
tiefkühlfach irgendwelche 1 boxen
gefunden mit eingefrorener alone asse so
oder so kennt ihr dieses schicke vanilla
ja auf jeden fall diese drei sorten
immer an einem eisbecher so richtig
packen weil sie nicht was es schauer
zucker waffe in teils mit kakao haltiger
fed glasur heils mit kokosraspeln sieht
aus wie dieses waffe läuft es seit 20
jahren nicht gegessen
ich bin zwar nicht aus der ddr aber ich
bekomme gerade so kindheits flashbacks
das schmeckt nach purer kindheit hat sie
meine kindheit versetzt werden wollte
und das gegessen haben durch was gäbe es
gebe ich von zehn bananen hier haben wir
wieder den den schokoladenhersteller
roth stern aus weißenfels und es gibt
sogar intra wieder drauf schokolade mit
reicht oft genauso wie schokolade sein
sollte
bitterschokolade bitterschokolade ist
milch rein machen
können wie laktose empfindlichen leute
endlich mal gehört werden das werde
jetzt nicht so krass sechs von zehn
männern als nächstes haben wir bambina
schokolade und ich hab am biener
schokolade entdeckt als ich nach berlin
gezogen bin ich hab's mal einfach
mitgenommen dachte mir ich habe ich noch
niemanden gesehen es ist die leckerste
schokolade diesseitig so laktose
empfindlich bin kaufe ich sie natürlich
nicht mehr so oft aber wo ist auch von
der marke seqis jetzt fragt ihr euch zu
recht aber was ist so besonders an
dieser sparte sind wenn man die jetzt
hier so berichten sie hat so eine
füllung die ist unglaublich lecker
hat das nie wieder essen dürfen jetzt
bin ich wieder zurück die einzigartige
mischung aus butter karamell gerüsteten
haselnuss splittern und feinster
vollmilchschokolade absolut stimmig zu
ich kann nicht beschreiben wie es
schmecke haselnuss oder karamell und
vollmilchschokolade stehen von 10 banane
die kann ich nicht probieren denn
natürlich noch an das video mit nina
kube als wir alles mit zitrone probiert
haben diese schokoladensorte mit zitrone
probiert haben und sie nicht mal
runterschlucken konnten
es wird ich würde mir die schmecken dann
habe ich die aufgemacht wo also dass das
hier sieht jetzt so nach richtig luxus
aus die ddr mensch lohmann original
mario mami mami mandelmilch - schokolade
armani
nun nahm ihn nun lohmann hoch seine
schokoladen schon
1888 offizieller tafel genuss im hof des
großherzogs von sachsen-weimar werden
noch heute mit erlesenen sorgfältig
aufeinander abgestimmten zutaten nach
traditionellen rezepturen hergestellt
wow ich habe noch nie so eine tolle
geschichte zu einer schokolade gehabt
feinste eine lesende geladen wo wir
jetzt hergestellt die delitzscher kommt
dort bildet zugeguckt du das eindruck
ist okay warum ist diese schule also
warm weil
so warm ist es hier nicht mein zimmer
sowie das kälteste zimmer
in dem
es schmeckt lecker schmeckt aber auch
wirklich so als auch schon so 1888 und
gegessen hat und es damals genauso
geschmeckt hat war ich mit dir aber
nicht empfehlen und ich glaube man muss
sich wirklich im kühlschrank ist es
wirklich hier nicht so waren drin
optisch aber toll die geschichte
dahinter super wir leben großherzöge
sechs von zehn bananen das machen wir
mal die frisur sind frecher müssen was
auch bei diesem produkt glaube ich
machen wir das gleiche prinzip wie bei
bambina in knackige haselnuss krokant
dreiecke umfeld von fine arts
abwehrspieler durch linken eigentlich
überhaupt nicht präsentation mit wieder
tipptopp sein deutet
ganz was für eines
hässliche kleine dreiecke
das ist so gar nicht mein geschmack
schmeckt als ob das kann schon verbrannt
wäre wirklich ist schmeckt verbrannt in
die schokolade schmeckt halt nicht so um
leckere schokolade auf meiner zunge zu
schnell sind ihr zu den leuten gehört
die das gerne kaufen und es ihnen
schmeckt super von mir kriegt ist eine
von zehn vornamen versehentlich gerade
für mich für mich für mich ist die kann
ich das ist das ein ddr 52 haselnüsse
für aschenbrödel wahrscheinlich sein das
original waffel solchen mid hw
trotzdem wird auch dabei dass von
unserer guten ostblock marke und stern
haben sie für das produkt eigentlich
irgend einmal die filmrechte gekauft
diesen film schon mal gesehen ich glaube
den gips auf netflix
rutschten
sehr lecker
komischen und auf der hinter packung
wird schon werbung fürs nächste produkt
gemacht für alle drei haselnüsse für
aschenbrödel fans wir haben noch ein
produkt mit ihrem gesicht ja gut
gemeinte sieben von zehn bananen
halloren kugeln ich liebe halloren
kugeln meinem exfreund der papa hat
irgendwo gearbeitet oder der wahl
irgendwo hat immer halloren kugeln zu
wahren ich glaube er hat in der nähe
boden punkt moment produziert in halle
hat er auf jeden fall hat er meine max
halloren kugel zu weihnachten geschickt
dann habe ich die probiert und seitdem
bin ich sehr lieb zwei kugeln wird
besser als keine
die haben wir nicht nur wenig so gut
geschmeckt sondern auch so seitdem nicht
mehr gegessen jetzt sind die in der
mitte
also die haben so schoko und so
nett gemeinte drei von zehn ban ich weiß
nicht warum das schmeckt mir heute
überhaupt denn sein muss man die aus und
kühlschrank ersten ich weiß es nicht
aber
das werde ich natürlich verlosen hier
ist der ort der safe ddr in denen so
sieht der ddr nudossi ohne palmöl sehr
gut
sagt okay nicht frei von zehn bargeld
der ddr zum essen ja lieb sven sachen
auch wirklich vintage aussehen nach
dassow findet 66 jahre fällige wenn
jetzt also haben wir einmal die sorte
mit zitrone und mit pfefferminz zu sehen
aus wie diese petzner sie sind petz
spende des stark macht
wisst ihr wie das schmeckt auf einen
mint packungen kaugummi und bonbons sind
auch immer diese hinweise bei zu vielen
verzehr kann es ab und wirken der
schmeckt so dass wenn ich viel davon
essen würde dann würde sich auf klagen
sind die stark also leute ich bin
begeistert die ddr hatte wirklich coole
sachen meine favoriten sind auf jeden
fall die knusperflocken und die bambini
schokolade aber das schon immer
und wie kann ich das wie konnte ich das
vergessen aber ich kann zwar immer
wieder betone ich liebe meinen job ich
hoffe ihr hattet spaß beim zuschauen wir
sind wenn das nicht immer wieder dann